- Okay, where are you from originally?
- So I was born and raised in San Diego,
but I have been in Denver
for the last 10 years
up until
this year
in March
which I hear out here and
I've been out ever since
- Went to, tell me about your challenges
- Yeah. So I was raised
me and
my four older brothers.
I'm the youngest and the only
girl and my father raised me.
My mom left me when I was, I
think about three years old.
She left me when I was
about five
and
till I was about
or 17,
- She came back at 16?
- Yeah.
And she was actually,
here, in Pasadena
homeless doing drugs.
And
Yeah, you know, she's never apologized
to me about it when I asked her about it.
You know, she blames
my dad saying, you know
he's the one that got her started
on drugs in the first place.
And I tell her, well, you know, he quit
because he had, you know,
five kids to raise four of us.
Aren't even his he's actually my
one of my brothers, father, that's it.
You know, I said,
excuse, I'm going to just
sit that right there.
And I said, you know, he quit
because he had five
kids to raise, you know
what's your excuse, you know?
And she'll never apologize, ever.
- Which drugs are you doing?
- I do crystal and heroine.
- Crystal?
- I've been doing crystal since I was 15
and I'm 28 it's 13 years
and I've been doing heroin for seven years
or eight years now since I was 20.
Yeah.
- Do you sometimes pick up guys?
- Oh yeah, I work.
I work out here.
I never worked until I came out here.
Up until I came out here
in
the end of January beginning of February
I had only been with
seven guys my whole life.
So obviously it's a lot more now.
You know, but I am always
careful, I'm more than safe.
- There's some crazy guys out there
Yeah. I mean, you never know every
every car you get in, you're
taking a risk you know,
but I have an addiction,
you know, and fortunately
- It's really hard.
- It is.
And you know, with heroin, I'm sure.
I don't know, you know, it's
not just a walk, you know
it's a physical dependency on it.
You know, like I quit last year
for
like eight nine months
from march all the way till
December and it was awesome.
- Now you're back in here
- So I came out here it's
supposed to be for 10 days.
I came out here with a truck driver
and
like I said I'd never worked
before I came out here,
but I met him in Denver and
he offered me $10,000 dollars
to
take a trip with him for 10 days
just to keep him company literally like
you know, the most I had done with him
like was rubbing his arm and
I already had $3,000 dollars.
Like, so that was just
from hanging out with him a day in Denver.
So when he offered me
$10,000 for just my company
10 day trip here and back,
like I said he's a truck driver.
I said, okay, sure.
You know, like I don't
generally do things like that
but for whatever reason
like I felt comfortable
enough with him to do it.
I didn't know he smoked crack
and I don't judge nobody,
you know, everybody, I do
you know what I do, you
know, I don't judge nobody
but if I had known it, might've, you know
I'm not saying I wouldn't
have come out here
but I might've had a little
bit more precautions, you know?
So we came out here and I guess
I don't know if he had been using
or he was just hiding it
or what, but maybe he had
a relapse when he came
to Skid Row or whatever.
So he, we ended up getting
in an argument down
and now that I know the
area it's like, it's funny.
So we got an argument down
on like 14th and Mattel.
Oh. So this was after we had been in here
for like maybe three days already.
And he was coming down here
to buy crack every day.
So
it was fine, no issues.
And so then we were sitting
on like 14th and Mattel
and we had been sitting
there for like three hours
and I, he turned and he told me
why have we been sitting
here for three hours?
And I said, because you
just want one more hit
one more hit, one more hit.
And he was driving it was his car.
Like, I don't even know why
he, so we drove truck out here.
And then he bought a Hummer.
When he got out here for like
$40,000 dollars, he paid cash.
We're driving the Hummer.
He we've been sitting
there for three hours.
He asked me, why have we been
sitting here for three hours?
And I said, cause you just
want one more hit one more.
Hey, he said, it's my car,
like, I'll do what the
fuck I want, what you up?
And I said, okay, well let me out.
And he had the child locks up.
I said, let me out I
just want to cool off.
I just want some fresh air, whatever.
So I got a car I slammed
the door like I was mad.
Oh, I told him like,
I said,
you ain't nothing but a crack head
with a little bit of money.
And I got out of the car
and slammed the door.
And then he took off.
I didn't think he was going to take off.
Like, and then he didn't
answer the phone for six hours.
And when he finally did, he said
I'm already on my way back to Denver.
And that's how I got here.
And that was back in.
So we left Denver like
the last month of January.
But like the beginning
February 1st I think is when
I got here, even back home
I was a functioning drug.
I was a general manager for six years.
You know, I have two kids.
You know, this is not me at all.
You know?
So.
Yeah.
- Where are your kids?
- Back home with their, their dads.
I had two kids, two different dads.
Okay. So my older son is with his father.
He's eight.
His dad is very well off.
I got with him when I was
18, but he is a nurse.
He owns his house.
He's got three cars, Camaro, a truck.
He does well for himself, you know?
And so he has my son.
I still have 50/50 custody of him.
And I've asked him like
why haven't you taken me back to court?
And he says, because I
know this isn't you V.
I know this is just a phase.
And, you know, get over it soon
hopefully for Jayden, you know?
Yeah. So he's with his dad.
And then my younger son is
with my ex-mother-in-law his grandma.
Because.
My
baby dad.
So last year when I quit using,
So me and my baby, my second baby dad,
we were together for six years.
And he's the one that actually
got me started on heroin.
So when I quit last year
and he didn't want to quit
I left him
Because ,
I had, I had always been the breadwinner
like I said, as a general
manager for six years.
And so, you know, when he didn't want to,
work or support his habit
or do anything, I said
I'm not going to work and hustle and this
that just to support your habit
like I'm not even getting
high anymore, you know
just so you're not sick.
And so we split up and he
ended up becoming homeless
in Denver and he's still
homeless in Denver.
And
My son is with his mother.
Who is actually
in the process of filing
for temporary custody
of my son.
- What ties do you have?
- Obviously, you know, to
get back home, but you know
this place is very, you
know, you get stuck.
- Yes
- So,
Yeah, like I miss my kids, you know, but,
I don't know like if this is guilt, like
if this is like terrible for
me to say, you know, but like
I'm not enjoying myself, but
like I am, I guess, you know
like I never did any of this.
You know, I got pregnant at 18,
and,
you know, I had both my kids every day
since the day they report.
And so,
yeah, I'm just, I never
experienced any of this
you know, I never got it out
of my system, you know, so.
- Do you talk to your kids?
- Yeah, my eight year old, I
talked to him, I video chat
with him and you know, he
asked me just the other day
actually he said, where are you mom?
I said, I'm still in LA, what
are you doing there anyways?
He told me, you know, like,
nothing Jay
you know, like.
So, you know
I know that they're both good right now.
You know, they're both safe.
They're both.
I was never a bad mom.
Like I was a really good mom.
I actually tell people, you
know, like the thing that I feel
like sucks right now is I
feel like my kids are missing
out on like a really
cool mom, you know, like,
sorry.
But,
Yeah, I feel like they're
good right now, you know?
And like I said, I was never a bad mom
but I definitely feel like
I need to be a lot better mentally.
And, and healthy, you know,
before I go back home.
So ,
may have a tissue please?
- Yeah
I guess that's, you know
my plan is to work on me
and
I don't know, you know
figure out who I am really, you know.
- All right.
Thank you for sharing your story.
- Of course